today the biggest threat to your freedom
of expression is not the federal
government it is powerful corporations
particularly tech corporations they can
fire you for speaking in their mind they
do do that they can censor you online
without you even knowing it Dennis
Prager is a radio show host knows a lot
about this he founded Prager you last
fall he sued Google saying that YouTube
is restricting his videos for being
conservative but of course you're not
giving liberal videos the same treatment
that lawsuit is ongoing Dennis Prager
joins us tonight Dennis thank you coming
up always good to be with you Tucker so
we've been following your suit both out
of affection for you but because we
think it has larger implications why is
this important beyond just the suit
itself the Internet is largely
controlled in terms of information by
Google which also you which also uses
and runs YouTube yes so if they don't
allow a free flow of information it
would be as if I don't know to make an
odd analogy your airport said only
people on the Left can fly airplanes can
can be passengers on airplanes that
would be an equivalent that is what is
now happening our lawsuit is so much
bigger than us it's big in and of itself
we have 600 million views last year and
that's probably why YouTube is not a big
fan of ours because we really are
effective we have four Pulitzer Prize
winners and we have professors from
Stanford Harvard Yale giving courses
these five-minute courses they're very
effective they they present a side of
life that has never heard or almost
never heard in on our campuses so they
have decided that they will put in this
case 40 of our 300 videos on the
restricted list meaning it's joined
pornography and violence being
restricted so for example we had a video
by Victor Davis Hanson who if you know
is the opposite of a flame thrower yeah
he is about as even-tempered a professor
as exists in the world and he gave a
thought why did we fight in Korea that
was on the restricted list after a big
battle its back its back on here's Alan
Dershowitz is a liberal he gave a car a
course titled
illegal founding of Israel that's on the
restricted list are you are you
convinced after going through this long
process and and digging into the suit
that Google's motives are ideological
there is no other possibility we have
videos on the exact same subjects as
liberal and left-wing videos they're
never sent certain hours but here by the
way is an amazing proof that is very
recent and not something I could have
told you the last time I was on your
show I debated a man from the left at a
synagogue in San Francisco a couple of
months ago and that was put on the
Internet they send they have put that on
a restricted list a debate in a
synagogue known for pornography and
violence needless to say apparently they
feel that I did better than the man on
the left and so they have put that on
the restricted list
it's transparently ideological and are
you convinced and I'm sure you've
gathered data on this that they're doing
this to a greater extent to sites on the
right than they are to sites on the left
yeah there's no there's no question
about it and our lawsuit that provides a
chapter and verse on precisely that
there's no question about that well this
is very trichomes yeah I'm sorry state
again what I was just saying well this
is I mean Google YouTube I mean these
are the ways that people understand
reality and so right yes if someone's
got his thumb on the scale then you're
not getting all the information you need
to make up your own mind right that's
why this lawsuit is important in and of
itself and it is important for another
equally important reason the court of
public opinion we need to say or Google
needs to say to be more precisely Google
needs to say the truth is we are not a
conduit for free expression we are here
to in fact promote our views that are on
the Left yes that's so either we'll even
get a win or will get honesty in either
way it's a win it is a win and and of
course we're hoping for your victory
dennis prager thanks a lot for
explaining that to us I appreciate it
thanks darker